ils réclament de meilleures conditions
de travail
épuisé par les vagues de co vide les
personnels de la santé de l'action
sociale sont à bout dans les rangs de la
manifestation aujourd'hui à tours
soignants sage femme ou encore
travailleurs sociaux ont donné de la
voix tristan rickli étaient sur place
ils sont en première ligne depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire et cette
fois ils sont dans la rue près de 600
travailleurs du secteur médico social
ont défilé à l'appel des organisations
syndicales
[Musique]
dépassés par le manque de moyens il
demande au gouvernement la hausse de
leurs salaires l'ouverture de lits et le
recrutement de personnel pour pouvoir
travailler à nouveau dignement il ya
beaucoup de
deux collègues qui démissionne parce que
faute de moyens et à des arrêts de
travail à des burn out parce que on
commence à ossature voilà où n'est pas
on était à 180 lits et là on aura
seulement 120 lits chine pour les
patients adultes donc ça fait peur ces
projets nous nous inquiète vraiment cool
une inquiétude partagée par les
travailleurs sociaux qui se sont jointes
au mouvement dans l'espoir de pouvoir
mieux accompagner les jeunes en
difficulté effectivement nous on est on
est dans des conditions qui sont pas
tous les jours facile et on n'est pas
toujours entendu auprès des politiques
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans des
secteurs où les éducateurs sont
pas toujours formés et
et c'est important qu'ils aient encore
des professionnels formés sur
l'établissement une journée de colère
chez les oubliés du ségur sur l'ensemble
du territoire national